I want to tell you a story now
and it has these characters in it and so
this is a very important story and it
gets,
it's called the Enuma elish and it's the
Mesopotamian creation myth and it's
important for a bunch of reasons.
First of all,
it's the oldest written story we know
of,
but it's also a Middle Eastern story and
the whole.
All the Abrahamic religions emerged out
of the Middle East and so it's a
foundational story.
It's a story that sits at the bottom of
our culture now.
It has.
It has similarities to the creation
story in genesis,
whether the creation story in genesis
was derived from it or whether there was
a whole variety of similar stories
floating around in the Middle East and
at the same time that we're very.
It's a theme we don't really know,
but it doesn't really.
I don't think it really matters.
We don't know how old the story is.
We know how old it is in its written
form.
It's,
it's,
it's thousands of years old and it's
written for them.
Maybe it's 10,000 years old.
It's written for him,
but probably not.
It's probably more like 5,000 years old,
but the thing is is that a 5,000 year
old story is a lot that's written is way
older than 5,000 years.
Like we're used to being in an
environment where there's a million
stories,
you know,
because we have books and movies and all
of these things,
but you know,
in,
in slower moving and more archaic
cultures,
especially ones that are just just have
an oral tradition.
It's not like there's a million stories.
There's like 20 canonical stories and
God only knows how old they are.
There was evidence,
linguistic evidence.
I just saw a study on this last week.
Someone sent it to me showing that some
of the fairytales that the grimm
brothers gathered might be 10,000 years
old.
And that doesn't surprise me because
the,
the kind of depth that's in a good fairy
tale is so the depth is so
the profundity is so deep that there's
no way that someone could just contract
it out.
You know,
100 years ago,
there's layers and layers and layers of
meaning and they're basically archetipal
and religious in significance.
And a Hansel and Gretel story is a good
example of that.
Um,
and sleeping beauty is a good example of
that too.
A lot of the canonical fairytales are,
they're very,
very powerful.
They pack a lot of meaning into a very
short
and do a very limited amount of time.
So.
So it was great that this was an arrest
and it was only on earth in the late 18
hundreds.
So we haven't known about this story for
a long,
long time.
And so it's,
it was a tremendously exciting discovery
on the part of the people who,
who dug it up.
So I'm going to tell you the story.
So
okay.
The primary character in this story is
a,
like a dragon mother named ty mapped and
tire map.
You can think about her as half the
dragon of chaos and half the destructive
creative feminine.
So she,
you could think about her as what sort
of on the border between what's a known
known in an unknown and unknown.
And she is construed as the mother of
all things.
Now,
the mother of all things is like what
was revealed when the towers came down
is this tremendously complex background,
multilevel system of operations that's
always going on that that identifiable
singular things emerged from now.
The mesopotamians wouldn't have said
that because what they said was this
story,
because that's the form in which their
knowledge had.
It had developed to the point where they
could tell a story about instead of
maybe acting it out or dreaming about it
in some sense,
you know,
but they couldn't articulate it.
We can barely articulate it now.
So there's time out.
She's viewed as the mother of all things
and she has a husband named absolute
who's her concert.
Very little is said about absolut in
this particular story,
and I think the reason for that,
although I'm not sure if this is that
the Mesopotamian civilization was new
enough as a technological state,
let's say,
because they made cities as a
technological state that the myth that
myths of humanity hadn't figured out how
to encapsulate the nature of the,
of our technological
dominance hierarchy.
There was a sense that it existed,
but there wasn't a sense of it as a
carer,
differentiated character that was
capable of doing all sorts of different
things.
I think that didn't emerge until Egypt,
although I'm not certain about that,
but that's how it looks to me.
So absolute is her husband.
Now,
the way the Mesopotamian started with
the world,
and this is the same way that the people
who wrote genesis started the world.
They thought that the world was a desk.
You know what,
what the world is like when you go
outside and you stand in a field.
It's a flat field.
You look at the world,
it's pretty obvious what it is.
It's a big disk of earth and then
there's a dome on top of it and in the
dome or the Sun and the moon and the
stars,
and then you might ask,
well,
what's underneath the earth?
And that the answer for the
Mesopotamians was fresh water first and
then sold water.
And how did you know that?
Well,
if you drilled down then up,
the fresh water would come.
So obviously it was fresh water down
there and then if you went to the edge
of your territory,
it's like,
well there's the salt water.
So the earth was,
you know,
the,
the earth,
roughly speaking,
was it disk of matter,
resting on a disk of fresh water,
resting on a disk of soap,
water and absolute time that were the
fresh and salt water respected.
Okay,
and now the Mesopotamians thought that
the way that the,
that absolutely time that gave birth to
everything was that they joined together
in sexual union.
It's like the Yin and the Yang and it's
very much like that in fact,
and that it was out of their union that
the,
the elemental God's emerged and I think
you can think of the elemental gods as
there are forces of nature and they're
viewed through.
They're not personified because to
personify something means that you see
it as an objective phenomena and then
attribute human characteristics to it.
That isn't how people work.
What happens is we perceive human
characteristics and then only with trip
terrible effort do we extract out the
objective reality from that.
So we depersonalize things when we
become scientific,
but we just naturally see them as
characters and you can see this when you
read books to kids,
you know,
like everything's a person that train is
a person in a car as a person that moon
is a person and the sun is a person and,
and you know,
you read stories to children that have
that as a presupposition,
doesn't bother you at all,
you know,
you,
you can just fall right into it with no
problem,
you know,
and in the automations you see the sun
in the sky smiling and bouncing along
and it doesn't bother you,
you know,
it's,
it's no problem to,
to look at the world that way and
there's some utility in looking at the
world in that way as,
as we'll discover.
So anyways,
and I think part of the reason that we
view things that way.
Oh yeah.
That was the other thing I wanted to
tell you about our perceptual systems is
that we.
We do have a social cognitive platform,
intellectual platform,
which means that our primary categories,
the primary categories of our mind do
seem to be social.
So you could say that the reason our
mind evolved or or.
No,
you could say that the fundamental
selecting pressures on our,
on our mind ensured that the,
the primary substructure of our
cognitive ability was modules that could
understand social behavior.
Man Can understand,
women,
women could understand men,
men and women could understand children,
children,
men and women could understand the
social world.
And that's.
And that's,
that's what we're specialized for.
And then it was only after those systems
develop hyper developed probably under
the,
under the force of sexual selection that
they became able to separate themselves
to some degree from that underlying
social cognitive structure and start to
see the world in ways that weren't
personified.
So,
but what that means is that our natural
categories are still an anthropomorphic
and dramatic and it actually turns out
that they work.
So absolute timeout,
nature and culture is a perfectly
reasonable way of thinking about them.
Now they would say,
well,
it's the interplay between nature and
culture that gives rise to the
primordial forces of nature.
Now those forces of nature would be to
some degree external like a storm or
like fire.
But they would be so to some degree
internal to like,
like the fire of passion,
right?
And the and the storm of sorrow.
Because those are natural forces as
well.
And one of the things that the ancients
knew was that man was created to serve
the gods.
And of course modern people think of
that as a superstition,
but that's because they don't really
understand how archaic people thought.
Archaic.
People thought.
Like Freud thought it was like,
yeah,
you have an ego fine.
You know,
and as long as you're in a box within a
bunch of other blocks is the eagle runs
things.
But as soon as we put you somewhere
where those boxes are gone,
it's the underlying forces of nature
that run you hunger,
thirst,
you know,
aggression,
sexuality and all those things that are
impersonal.
Because of course you have them and you
have them,
and so does everyone else,
so they're impersonal and transcendent
and they're also eternal,
and so when the art or arcade people
said,
and they usually said this with sorrow,
that man was destined to serve the gods.
That's what they meant.
They meant that we were the play.
Things have these unbelievably powerful
primordial forces that manifested
themselves within our lives and
determined our destinies in,
in,
in fact,
the Mesopotamian said that specifically
about the elder gods.
They said they were.
They were part of that which determined
human destiny.
They monitor who will talk about in a
while was given the tablet of destinies
because when he was,
when he asked to become top God,
he said,
well,
if I'm going to be taught God,
I get to determine the destinies and
well,
we'll get to that.
So you kinda got to know what these,
what these archaic,
God's work.
And they were personalities.
You know,
when you could say,
well,
yeah,
maybe it's a mistake to attribute the
qualities of personality to a storm.
Although it depends on what you think a
storm is,
like a modern person would think of a
storm as an objective event that you
have subjective reactions to,
and our keg person would more likely
think of the storm as the subjective
consequences of the storm,
plus the storm all at once.
They would make that separation,
so it's a lot easier to personify
something under those conditions or to
not to personify it,
but to.
But to stay within the realm of
conceptualization that makes it a
persona.
Find Force.
So the storm God is something that you
know,
that can instill terror into your heart.
It's like,
well,
you know,
yeah,
fair enough.
You know?
All right,
so anyways,
absolutely tie.
They give rise to these primordial gods
and I'm going to think about them as
forces of nature and I think that's a
reasonable representation for a variety
of reasons.
They're like the titans.
All right,
so the giving rise to these gods and the
gods are their children and they run
about making all sorts of racket.
They were making rockets and they're
doing this and they're doing that and
they're building things in there,
messing about with things in their,
their noisily engaged in their
interactions with one another and
they're having children and they're
fighting about sex and they're just
making racket like mad and then they do
something stupid and so they're annoying
time that as they make all this racket,
she's sorta slumbering down there in the
depths
leaving them be,
but they make all this racket that may
annoy her.
It's like it's the environmentalist myth
by the way.
It's exactly the same idea.
So you know,
human beings,
we're kind of dopey.
We're running around gratifying our
fundamental needs and making racket and
destroying things,
and if we're not careful,
mother nature will come flooding back
and wipe us out.
It's like,
yeah,
that's happened in the past.
It could happen,
but it's an archetypal.
It's an archetypal idea.
It's a mythological idea.
So fine.
They're making racket and timeouts,
leaving the beach,
but then they get arrogant,
I would say,
or careless and they,
they kill app suit and they make their
dwelling place on his corpse.
Now that's a that is a brilliant,
brilliant symbolic idea because what it
means,
it means a bunch of things,
but one of the things that means is that
in so far as the gods are because
they're masculine,
you're part of the representation of the
dominance hierarchy and the human
interactions within it,
that the idea that that,
that that's all existing on the corpse
of absolute is something like the idea
that all of the natural forces that are
embodied within human beings and driving
them are resting on a substructure of
dead culture and everyone knows that
because everyone says,
especially modern people,
they look back at their culture and they
think,
oh,
that thing's dead.
You know,
and we can rest comfortably on its debt
surface.
Well,
that's not right because if it's dead,
well,
if it's dead,
logically speaking,
it's not alive,
and if it's not alive,
it can't adapt.
And if it doesn't adapt and it falls
behind and gets full of errors and it
gets corrupt and starts to fall apart,
and if it gets corrupted full of errors
and falls apart enough,
then chaos comes back.
That's exactly what happens in the
Mesopotamian myth.
So they kill app soon.
They keep making racket and time at
wakes up one day and she thinks,
oh,
they're noisy,
I don't like them that much and now
they've gone and done in my husband,
which is order,
so I'm going to wait them out.
So the guards get wind of this and
they're not very happy about it,
you know,
because after all they're gone.
But she is the god goddess slash drag
that gave them all life and the
probability that they'll prevail in a
battle against that which gave them form
is very,
very low.
So they're pretty damn terrified.
So meanwhile time at is generating her
army and she generates quite an army and
that Mesopotamians list out what she
does.
She,
she first of all picks for her concert,
a new character named king and king who
is like the king of the demons monsters.
So her old husband was app.
So when maybe he was ordered and her new
husband is like,
he's not someone that you want to have
around at all.
And so he's basically put at the hand of
this flanks of terrible monsters and she
generates like Scorpion monsters and
crocodile monsters and all sorts of
things in our army so that she can go
wipe out these,
these gods.
And so while this is happening,
the gods gathered themselves together
and they decide that they will elect a
champion from within their ranks to go
out and fight with tire map.
And so they do that and they send one
God out and he comes back with his tail
between his legs,
roughly speaking.
All right,
don't lie,
encounter with chaos.
And then they send another God out.
The same thing happens and they send
another God out at the same thing
happens.
And it's getting pretty damn hopeless
because they're sending out their best
men against chaos and the,
and the mother of all things.
And they're getting scoble all the time
while this was happening.
They continue to produce new generations
of Gods.
And at one point this new God emerges
as,
as a young person,
I presume.
Um,
but he's,
he's,
there's some things that are different
than about him than any other thing
that's being produced so far.
And one of the things that's different
is he's,
he's quite tall and powerful,
so,
you know,
that's not necessarily so radical,
but he has eyes all the way around his
head and when he speaks he can speak
darkness into being an,
he can speak light into being.
So,
so things obey the commands of his
words.
So He's a master of language.
He can see everywhere and he's a master
of language.
Okay.
And so the garlands and checking them
out and they think,
wow,
you know,
he's,
he's quite something,
maybe we can get him to go after time,
Matt.
So they all go to him in this,
in this little group and they say,
look,
Marduk,
because that's his name.
Um,
you know,
we've been checking you out and you're
looking pretty impressive.
And so we've got a proposition for you.
I,
how about if you go fight time map and
Marta,
who's not only all seeing and,
and very capable with languages,
no fool.
And he says,
yeah,
I get what you want,
but here's the deal.
You get everybody together first and
I'll go fight your monster,
but you're going to have a congress and
add that Congress.
You're going to elect me king of the
gods,
and then I'll go fight time map.
And so of course the other gods aren't
very happy about this,
but they go off and they have a congress
and they invite mark to it and they talk
about it and they realize they don't
really have any other choice.
So they decided that they're going to
elect Marduk to the top of the hierarchy
of gods.
Now that's such a smart idea.
So if you think,
for example,
you can think of a hero and then you
could take,
if you took 10 heroes and average them
out of that,
you get a a God,
right?
So it'd be 10 heroes.
You get Annetta here out of that,
and that would be a.
and then maybe you do that to 10 sets of
10 heroes and you get 10 mega heroes.
And then you take all those mega heroes
and you figure out what's the same about
them and you abstract that out and then
you get the hero of heroes of heroes.
And that's the archetype.
That's the archetype.
It's a process of distillation.
It's like who is the most interesting
possible,
the most interesting and capable
possible person will that would be this
person.
This is the most memorable possible
Well,
we don't know who that is,
but this is how we figured out how I
could say,
well,
I admire something about you and I
admire something about you.
I can notice that as a phenomenal
logical fact.
You seem very capable in a certain way
and you know you have this attribute.
And then I might say,
well,
if I was going to sort out an ideal for
myself to follow,
then I take the good parts of all of
you.
And I put that into one thing and then I
would make that my ideal.
Well,
that's the origin of the idea of the
savior of the Messiah is it's an
emergent idea emerges when people notice
that the hero is that the hero is part
of the forest that makes order out of
chaos.
Or sometimes the reverse.
When when order has become too rigid,
it can also decompose order bringing a
little necessary chaos into it,
rejuvenate the whole structure.
So anyways,
so Marta,
he gets elected king.
Now you might think about how would this
happen historically speaking?
Well,
here's an interesting way of thinking
about it.
So imagine a landscape that consists of
tribes,
okay?
And then on top of them,
imagine a landscape of the imagination.
Okay,
so each member of each tribal group
lives in their imagined world and that
imagined world is full of diabetes and
natural forces of various kinds that
they're following.
But then you can imagine that as the
tribes battle it out and organize
themselves,
the fingers of the imagination do
exactly the same thing.
So as the people are battling,
the Gods in heaven are battling,
which is also a very common mythology,
and as the human beings a beat
themselves into a functional group,
their world conceptions do the same
thing.
And so over time you move from
polytheism,
roughly speaking to monotheism as the
the,
as all of these tribes communicate with
one another in,
in language and in and in combat,
and sort out just exactly what should be
sovereign,
what should it be?
Powerful,
Dominant,
right?
It's a major.
It's a major issue and it's partly
practical.
It's partly conceptual.
So if this is reflected in the
Mesopotamian creation myth,
the gods assemble themselves and they
look among them and they think,
okay,
well some one here is,
has the characteristics that should,
should be the central element of the top
daddy,
which is like the ultimate value.
Okay,
well the Mesopotamians chose wisely
vision and language.
Those are your most,
the most potent weapons you have against
chaos because you,
if you pay attention,
you can see chaos when it first emerges.
And then if you are a master of
language,
you can encapsulate it,
then articulate it very rapidly,
and you can communicate that to other
people's.
It's like now this easy.
You just cannot overestimate how radical
an idea that is.
It's a staggeringly radical idea that
that's the set of attributes that should
be at the top.
The mesopotamians were trying to figure
out what should be sovereign,
what should be above everything else.
Well,
you might say a person,
it's like,
yeah,
no,
the person embodies sovereignty.
Sovereignty itself is something else.
So when Frans de Waal,
for example,
he was watching chimpanzees hash it out
for dominance in,
in the,
in the zoo.
I think it's in the R and M,
I think.
Anyways,
it's a zoo that has a lot of chimpanzees
and he spent a lot of time watching
them.
And you know,
one idea about the dominant chimp is
that he's just the biggest meanness,
like most tyrannical chimp.
It's sort of the strong man theory of
chimp leadership.
But what do all observed was that,
well that was sort of true in that the
strongest,
meanest chimpanzee could obtain
dominance.
But the problem with him is if he was
really like selfish and cruel,
was that he didn't have any friends.
Now chimps have friends and they spent a
lot of time with them and they groom
each other and they protect each other
and fights and like,
you can be the ugliest,
meanest chimp around.
But if there's two chimps that are three
quarters your strength coming at you,
it's like you,
you lose now.
So that means two chimps that are
capable of enough civilization to find
themselves in to a dyad that is,
that has mutual obligations across time,
is way stronger than one ship who
doesn't.
And so what that means is that strength
and viciousness,
you know,
there'll be times when that can emerge
as the dominant power,
but it's very,
very unstable.
And,
and everyone's motivated to bring it
down as fast as possible.
And the best way to bring it down is
with the coalition.
And so partly what that indicates is
that it's actually the chimp who's the
best at making coalitions that's most
likely to become sovereign.
So that,
and that's actually what happens with
the chimps is that,
uh,
the dictator chimp is very unstable.
And in the one story I read it of Arnhem
Zoo,
he rose to the top,
the,
you know,
bad,
bad guy,
the gangster guy and a two chimps went
after him and to pieces.
They tore off his testicles.
Yeah.
And you know,
it agitated the hell out of the rest of
the truth.
And it was like a bloody revolution,
you know,
it was really,
really stressful for the troop.
But,
but what it indicates,
and it's so interesting,
is that the idea that in a,
in a dominance hierarchy,
what's most dominant is power.
That there's no evidence whatsoever that
that's true.
And in fact,
I was talking to when I have a partner
in a business that I have,
who was a student of mine at Harvard,
he's a very,
very smart person and I was talking to
him about dominance hierarchies and he
said something very that I found very
upsetting on a variety of levels.
He said it's not a dominance hierarchy
if you can't put a dog collar on the
person one level below you,
which is pretty bloody blunt statement,
but when he's he,
he's prone to that sort of thing,
but what he meant is that it's possible
that the idea that the term dominance
hierarchy is not the right term to be
applying to these sorts of social
structures because what it implies is
that what keeps the structure in place
is power.
You know,
and that's the sort of claim that people
like food,
coal make.
It's all about power.
It's like the thing is,
it's not all about power.
It's not all about power.
It's not all about power among animals.
So with power,
with chimps,
if that's all you've got is power,
you're going to get wiped out.
You have to.
So what I found was that the chimps who
were able to establish stable patterns
of leadership were quite congenial.
They had a lot of allies,
so they engaged in mutual grooming and a
lot of social interaction and they were
very positively predisposed to the
females in the truth.
So that's pretty interesting,
you know,
because we don't know what constitutes
valid sovereignty,
but even in animals it doesn't seem to
be power.
So,
and then you know,
you look at wolf packs and that sort of
thing and you know,
if two wolves go at it for,
for dominance,
one wolf of back off and roll over and
show his throat and you know,
like Stalin,
Wolf would just tear out his throat.
But you know,
Churchill Wolf let say would say,
well yeah,
you're kind of useless,
but we might need you around later.
So why don't you get up and you know,
we'll let bygones be bygones and that's
what wolves do,
you know,
and unsurprisingly,
because what are you going to do?
Kill everyone in your troop?
Well that doesn't seem like a very
effective strategy either for meeting or
for survival.
So the Mesopotamians were trying to work
out practically who's going to be
sovereign and at the same time
conceptually what is the proper basis
for sovereignty,
which is really the ultimate question in
some sense.
So anyways,
so they elect Marduk and the markets go
to all these eyes and he can speak.
And so he thinks,
all right,
he says,
if I win,
I'm going to get the tablet,
have destinies,
and then I'm taught God.
And they say,
yeah,
whatever,
if you win,
no problem.
So he goes out to fight time and he
takes a sword and he and he takes a net
and they meet on the battlefield and he
encapsulates timeout in a net,
which I think is a brilliant,
brilliant metaphor again,
because chaos is a morphous and
unformed,
right?
And if you want to conquer it,
you have to encapsulate it within a net,
a net.
You have to,
you have to make it into something
rather than something amorphous.
You know,
when.
So look,
maybe a client comes to me and they say,
Oh,
I've been having these terrible symptoms
on my heart races and I,
I,
my,
my breath,
I can't catch my breath and I think I'm
going to die.
And um,
I think maybe I'm having a heart attack
and I'm always at the hospital and they
tell me that there's nothing wrong with
me,
but I have like,
I'm,
I'm afraid all the time and I'm starting
not to go out.
And I say,
Oh,
you have agoraphobic.
Yeah,
lots of people have that.
You're not the only person like that in
the world.
Not only that it has a name,
we know what to do about it,
and there's a treatment course and
they'd go.
And the reason for that is that the
unknown unknown has just been turned
into a known unknown and that's a
massive improvement.
And so the person who conceptualizes the
anomalous situations fastest is in fact
the leader.
That's the definition of leadership.
It's like we don't know what's going on.
This is what's going on and what.
And when you say,
this is what's going on,
you also simultaneously say,
here's a million other things that could
have been going on that aren't.
So it's a process of radical
simplification and it lowers the stress
levels immediately.
Anyway,
so time that goes in or articles,
he gets her in a nap and then he splits
in half and he makes heaven out of one
half and the earth out of the other for
the human beings and uh,
and he goes back to any defeats,
Keto and all the monsters.
And then he goes back to tell the other
gods and they're pretty happy about
this.
And he knew had the tablet,
the destinies,
but Martin took that from him and now he
has it.
So he gets to determine destiny and he
makes human beings out of king whose
blood,
which is quite an interesting little
twist to the story and he makes them to
serve the gods.
And so,
so that's that.
So,
so the idea is that the,
the hero who can see and can communicate
is also the hero who separates out the
elements of existence so that it becomes
a habitable place and that humans should
serve that serve.
Margo.
Well,
you have to serve something.
you're going to serve a natural force of
some sort of you gonna be all anger.
You can be all last,
are going to be all love,
we can be all hunger,
or are you going to represent some
integrated,
ah,
some some balanced and integrated
emergent property of that.
It's also socially constructed and also
that you're a balance of natural forces
and you're a civilized person.
That's some sort of essence and that's
what you're going to strive for.
Well,
that's Marta,
so you're supposed to be a good murder.
Now,
Margaret is immortal now.
The only person who was identified with
Martech in the Mesopotamian realm was
the emperor.
Now they lived in a walled city,
and so what the emperor,
the reason the emperor was sovereign was
because he was supposed to be the
embodiment of Marico and earth,
which meant that his job was to
transform chaos into order whenever
chaos threatened.
He was supposed to transform it back
into order.
So this is what Mesopotamians did at the
New Year's celebration when the year is
rejuvenated,
right?
The old year dies.
Of course we know that because we still
do it,
and the new year is this new baby.
It's a time of new beginnings.
So the Mesopotamians would take the
emperor out of the city and they'd strip
him of all his emperor close,
and then they'd make them recite all the
ways during the last year that he'd been
a bad Marduk,
like he hadn't kept,
he hadn't been encountering chaos
properly and hadn't been keeping order
property,
so and confess all of his inadequacies.
Then the priest would whack them with a
glove as a,
you know,
as a ritual punishment,
and then they take all the statues out
of the old gods out of the city,
and then they really represent the
battle between Martech and tire mount,
and then the emperor was mark and he
would win and then he would have sex
with a ritual prostitute,
which was that.
This is a much tougher concept,
but it's a way of symbolizing the fact
that if the creative force encounters
the positive element of the feminine,
it's like the prince and sleeping
beauty,
getting sleeping beauty from the grasp
of the evil queen who turns into the
Dragon.
It's exact because it's weird,
right?
You've seen that and you understand it.
Right?
Sleeping.
Beauty's all in the tower.
She's covered by,
she's hemmed in by a huge fields of
thorns.
The Evil Queen is trying to stop the
prints from getting to her.
She turns into a dragon which makes
absolutely no sense,
but everyone follows it and then he has
to fight his way through that to get to
the,
to the main.
It's the same idea in a different
context and then order productive order
being reestablished.
Everybody goes back into the kingdom and
it's renewed for the next year and
that's the idea behind Mesopotamian
sovereignty and it's bloody brilliant
because it's an abs.
It's,
it's,
it's the beginnings of,
of law.
In some sense.
It's,
it's the idea that to be,
to be proper,
even if you're a desperate,
even if you're the king,
there's a sacred pattern of behavior
that you must adhere to,
which is the consequence of a congress,
of the gods deciding what the most
effective mode of being is.
It's staggeringly brilliant and,
and it took that story.
We just have no idea how long that story
took.
Do we merge?
I would say it's,
it's the consequence of the full course
of human evolutionary history.
Like the,
there are elements in it that are as old
as mammals and maybe older than that,
you know,
if you think about those patterns being
embedded in behavior long before they
were abstracted out into
representations,
it's unbelievably archaic and ancient
and so you have time at the great
mother.
You have absolutely the great father,
you have Marduk the archetypal son,
you have king who's the negative element
of Marta,
right?
And you have the drama of all those
characters interacting across time and
that's,
that's the mythological,
mythological representation of reality.
And tying that to tie it into the
neuropsychology that we talked about,
you know,
we talked about anomaly,
right?
And how normally you have a,
a,
a box that you're in that is your world,
but that box doesn't contain everything
in the world.
There's a lot of things that are good at
and sometimes they poked their head in
like a snake and then that's disruptive.
And what do you do?
Well,
you have to,
you have to voluntarily encounter the
snake then either defeated or make
something valuable out of it.
You know,
you could cower and hide,
but all that generally means the state
grows and grows until there's hardly any
you in the box and there's all snake and
that's actually the Mesopotamian
stories.
It's like if the elder gods weren't so
careless and had been paying attention
and hadn't killed absolute time,
that would've stayed asleep the whole
time.
So.
Well.
So that's the,
that's the level of isomorphism.
So what's,
what's fascinating,
but I think inevitable is that the
mythology reflects the physiology,
but how could it not?
The physiology produced the mythology,
like,
of course that's going to be the case.
It shouldn't be a surprise.
It should be,
it should be,
it should be.
The reverse should be a surprise.
It's like there's no relationship
between these,
these old stories and the way that human
beings are structured.
It's like,
well,
no,
that's a dumb idea.
So,
well,
that's the Mesopotamian creation myths
and it's,
it's a killer.
It's,
it's a,
it's a staggering story.
And you know,
it still sits.
Whether we know it or not,
it sits at the very base of our culture.
It's absolute that story.
And if we kill it,
which we will or have been,
then then look out,
you know,
we know the story from so long ago,
if you let your culture die and act
carelessly towards it,
all hell will break loose and it's no
joke.
So,
so here we are trying to revive a fight.
It's pretty weird that these things
happened to be real.
But then if you think about it,
well,
how could it be otherwise?
You know,
I mean,
you think all these people who lived
before us for the tens of millions of
years that we've had are vaguely human.
Pre predessessors were stupid.
They weren't and they weren't ignorant
and they weren't superstitious or any of
those things.
They were,
they were,
they were tough enough so that we're
here.